all right as we speak the president is
conducting a series of meetings with the
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un they
just met they shook hands they had a
photo op and tomorrow the president will
join us right here on this program for
an important one-on-one and you'll bring
inside that room but we didn't begin
tonight how did we get here and we want
to detail the president's calls how
political opponents of the president of
purposely trying to create artificial
unrealistic expectations so that they
could oh this is a failure when we've
gotten so much out of this already
before it even started no one predicted
that these talks would immediately
result in the complete and total
denuclearization of North Korea this is
going to be a process as the Secretary
of State mark Mike Pompeo said well the
hard work actually begins after the
summit and it's very important to
remember what President Trump what he
just said a few days ago he told us
exactly that this is a process it's a
long process and here's what he said our
people have been in Singapore our people
have been working very very well with
the representatives of North Korea so
we're going in with a very positive
attitude and I think we're going to come
out fine but I've said it many times who
knows who knows may not may not work out
it's a good chance it won't work out
it's probably an even better chance that
it will take a period of time it'll be a
process
so this is going to be an ongoing
process Kim jong-un going as the
president said he can go at his own face
pace he can go faster he goes slower now
obviously we can't forget the
untrustworthy nature of Kim jong-un and
his predecessors we learn from history
now North Korea won't agree to our terms
the president well he stated many times
he will walk away that would be the
right thing to do he read he canceled
his meeting once and they were kind of
begging him to come back one thing is
certain
this president's not going to be duped
into sending cash loads of or cargo
planes full of cash like Bill Clinton
did in the 1990s promising all they'll
never get nuclear weapons we know that
the former President President Clinton's
policy in North Korea was an abject
failure kissing the rings of despots it
doesn't work trying to bribe them
doesn't work
frankly it's a form of insanity in order
to avoid these historical mistakes and
Clinton's blunder well we hope president
and it seems to leading up to this no
the president is now following the lead
of a predecessor named for Ronald Reagan
and just like President Trump
Reagan deployed a policy of philosophy
of peace through strength trust but
verify a very aggressive military
posture and just like Trump vagin had
very tough words for America's biggest
foe the Soviet Union for some of you you
may not remember this but it's worth
learning the lessons of history or we're
doomed to repeat the failures take a
listen they preach the supremacy of the
state declare its omnipotence over
individual man and predict its eventual
domination of all peoples on the earth
they are the focus of evil in the modern
world so in your discussions of the
nuclear freeze proposals I urge you to
beware the temptation of pride the
temptation of blithely declaring
yourselves above it all and label both
sides equally at fault to ignore the
facts of history and the aggressive
impulses of an evil empire to simply
call the arms race a giant
misunderstanding and thereby remove
yourself from the struggle between right
and wrong and good and
right and wrong good and evil force of
evil evil empire it's important to
remember President Reagan was not afraid
to walk away from the negotiating table
this is very key before effectively
ending the Cold War Ronald Reagan in his
1986 one-on-one talks with Mikhail
Gorbachev without reaching any kind of
deal he walked away in Reykjavik and
Iceland and of course tonight we have
many reasons to be hopeful now already
as I've been saying in many ways the US
has made more diplomatic progress right
here well in North Korea were in
Singapore than any other previous
administration Kim jong-un he dismantled
one of his nuclear testing sites
he stopped testing intercontinental
ballistic missiles remember he was
firing them over Japan threatening Guam
threatening the entire region he's
temporarily I was back in December and
he ended all those nuclear tests he
released three American hostage hostages
he walked across the DMZ and had
friendly talks with the South Korean
president president moon and now for the
first time in history he's sitting down
right there as we speak and without
hesitation without any concessions from
the United States this is a point that
media hasn't made none zero he's given
nothing and we have gotten concessions
that nobody predicted and the president
is demanding complete verifiable
irreversible denuclearization this is
obviously a worthy goal you care about
your kids your grandkids you want a
safer world this is a good day for you
at least we have hope now it was
primarily achieved how did we get here
for two main strategic reasons first
president's peace through strength
strategy it works it works every time
why don't we don't follow it I don't
know he sent multiple carrier strike
forces to the region he ramped up
military drills he tightened the screws
on an increased sanctions program the
sanctions alone of crippled North Korea
is a horrible economy so make no mistake
in North Korea today their situation is
dire and Kim jong-un's Kingdom deals
with widespread hunger and poverty that
is a threat to his power and by the way
on a scale we're not seeing anywhere
else in the world and as Kim jong-un
comes here they could take a look at
just how beautiful South Singapore is
and say
hmm maybe we can do this in my country
because the North Korean economy is so
distressed even Kim Jong remember
reportedly need of financial assistance
to get a hotel room here in Singapore
I'll let him stay with me if he wants
I'll sleep on the couch anyway it's a
primary way this is the important lesson
Trump forced Kim jong-un to the
negotiating table through an improved
relationship with the Chinese president
China's North Korea's biggest ally
trading partner many analysts believe
that China holds the key to a safe
Korean Peninsula he can pressure Kim
jong-un and his regime like no other
country and so tonight the world is
watching we're watching here in
Singapore and you still have people on
the left predictably I've said many
times that if the president actually
gave a million dollars or more to every
American citizen you'd have people on
the Left saying why is it at a million
two million and there are people that
president Trump's success is a failure
for them in other words they want these
talks to go nowhere you think the
Democrats want the president to do well
here there are people who have been
wrong about Donald Trump our president
every single step of the way some
pundits so-called journalists fake news
they claimed all Trump is leading us to
a nuclear holocaust because of his tough
words and anxious and actions against
North Korea the same people let me see
they predicted and laughed at the idea
that Trump could win the Republican
primary they laughed at the idea he
could beat Hillary Clinton
the same people didn't believe the
Trump's economic agenda would be this
successful than 500 days the same people
who predicted president Trump would
already be impeached by now and of
course President Trump won the election
the economy soaring we have the lowest
unemployment rate in half a century we
have more jobs available in America than
we have people to fill them on the
unemployment lines the lowest
unemployment rate in 14 states lowest
unemployment record for
african-americans Hispanic Americans
women in the workplace more jobs
available than people on unemployment
pretty amazing for 500 days GDP growth
it's at a faster pace than at any time
during the eight years of Obama
oh yeah and President Trump is still in
office no legitimate threat of
impeachment not a
of evidence about Trump Russia collusion
he's constantly wrong in the fake news
media he's overpaid lazy so-called
journalists really it makes them look
bad when the president's successful and
it helps our country it helps the world
oh and for Democrats they want to get
back in power I get it if he's
successful that doesn't help them anyway
once again this has been on a grand
scale people have underestimated Donald
Trump again and again and sadly even
some of them want to him to be failing
so they can be proven right and many are
incapable of ever reporting objectively
on this president and by the way now
some are even claiming Trump wasn't
prepared for the summit yes you'll never
win watch this he has been preparing for
this all along in his imagination know
there is a difference between studying
up for it this is not a dog who likes to
learn new tricks he relies on the same
methods over and over again we've been
told that Kim has been preparing for
months the president tells us he will
depend on instinct feel and touch what
I'm really worried about with President
Trump is this whole thing you know I'm
God's gift I will go in in a moment and
I will know within 30 seconds whether
there will be a deal or not and whether
I know the history of North Korea
doesn't matter it doesn't matter he said
I've been preparing all my life I'd love
to know mr. president when was that when
you appeared in Playboy softcore porn
movie was it when you bodyslam Vince
McMahon the head of the World Wrestling
Federation or was it when you were
leaking information when you were
disguising yourself as your own PR guy
talking to tabloids about what a great
lover you were it's it's now so obvious
and transparent to everybody where these
people are coming from the president
said this is something you prepare for
your whole life you don't ever stop
preparing now the media some of their
friends in the Democratic Party okay
they've got their position we understand
and by the way if the president succeeds
think about this is this good for the
world or not good for the world good for
your kids and grandkids are not good for
your kids or grandkids anyway bad news
for them that's sad